[Music]
so hi everyone thanks for coming to my
talk it's great to speak at the sort of
a homecoming event like this again
my name is Vinson I've been organizing
the PI date for a while and I would love
to talk to you about what I think is one
of the biggest problems out there and
because I think as a data scientist
community and as sort of if I look at
what people doing with data and I must
say like this is not necessarily based
on stuff I see actual human beings do
it's also stuff that I read of and like
hacker news and stuff but I think we are
sometimes in a profession of solving the
wrong problem and there's a couple of
two stories and like I'll show you share
some theory theory of failures and stuff
but before I sort of explain what I'm
gonna talk about during the entire talk
I kind of want to tell you a true story
and as a crowd I would love to remind
you that this is a true story this
actually happened it is the first
failure I've ever experienced using data
I must stress it actually happened it's
also something I learn a lot from
but it is also super embarrassing
because it is the story of the first a
plus it's also the only a plus that I
forgotten in college if they imagine the
stories kinda like this like some of you
probably had like an educational
background where you also had this first
year class in statistics and very
typically what the professor's really
like you to do is you know you have your
first year statistics you know what a
regression is then the teacher says go
out there and find yourself a real-world
data set and apply statistics to it and
there were some students who were doing
like I remember a friend of mine doing
like research on you know the population
size of a country and how many Olympic
medals you might win etc but as it was
while I was doing this gig about what
was doing statistics I had a gig like a
job at a bar and a local theater and the
theater just celebrated its 12th year
anniversary and they kind of had a
problem because they were thinking about
maybe expanding but they didn't really
know for sure so I asked for their data
about their like growth rates and stuff
and they happily gave to me and then
hopefully I could apply statistics and
if I could apply statistics I would both
impress my boss who might give me a
raise and I might get an A from the
professor so the chart I'm about to show
you was made in like 2007 so it was made
with illustrator I had to actually
manually draw every single rectangle
like this so thank you to all the math
filled lib committers that we don't have
to do it anymore but the graph that
you're looking at is sort of the growth
rate so like a year one there was like a
growth compared to the year before what
we're doing is we're checking how many
people were in a room the year before
and how many people in the room now like
in a theater room so to say hey you know
the beginning you see the growth was
like pretty high and then after that the
gross kind of low and then you know
twelve data points so I did what my
professor asked me I put the linear
regression line through this and it had
to be significant right that's great so
even if you have 12 points of data
statistically you can sort of point out
that something might be significant and
this gave me statistical evidence to
point out that the theater should not
expand because clearly the growth have
been stagnated and the teacher loved it
because the teacher actually said yo you
actually went out there and you got like
a business case you solved it within a
couple of weeks ten out of ten so you
know the best the futures looking great
because I'm a young kid and I can do you
know data science I'm gonna be a
enterprise person wear a suit make money
and all that then two years like two
days later I was at the same bar at the
same theater and you know you know these
evenings I mean you're behind the bar
and like the house is like super path
like this everyone's sweating because
it's so packed it was one of these
nights and then the week after I had
another one these nights where the house
was like super packed and like people
were sweating and stuff so then I
started thinking you know technically
you cannot sell more tickets if every
chair and a theater is taken so the
growth might have stagnated it simply
because there were no more seats to sell
and if you doesn't put a model through
the thing that says yeah the growth has
stopped you are measuring the wrong
thing and you were sort of solving the
wrong problem and this definitely
happened my boss was super happy with
the result my statistics professor was
super happy to result but this was one
of those moments where I was so focused
on the method that I completely
neglected the fact that I was chasing a
vanity task and as always at these sort
of moments where you look yourself in
the mirror and you say crap I solved the
wrong problem and it's not just me I
think a lot of people a lot of times
they're having this problem over and
over and over again you know like
solving problems is hard I'm not
suggesting that solving problems is
always super easy but lately I've
noticed that exactly what happened to me
when I was like in college I see that
happens to like a bunch of people I've
noticed that algorithms are sort of
starting to distract us from what we're
actually supposed to do and like there's
a lot of hype
hacker news and whatnot like that the
algorithm might save us right there's a
lot hyper and deep learning and all
these things but in this talk I kind of
hope to convince you that it's all stuff
around the algorithm that's actually a
solution that maybe the algorithm itself
is not really a special citizen or
anything like that but if we are able to
convince ourselves of this that maybe
we're gonna be much better at making
solutions and I'll share a few stories
one story by the recommender one story
about rephrasing and world hunger one
story about a kaggle hack which the
funniest thing and a story about a time
series task so I hope we're excited
about that I'm assuming that at least a
lot of you are Dutch and if you're Dutch
you've probably noticed this website for
those of you that are not familiar with
this website basically this is the Dutch
BBC and for those of you don't like
juice - Dutch BBC does online television
it's like Netflix and if you're not
familiar it's Netflix welcome to my idea
but so the idea is when you pause the
video or when you're like at the end of
the video there's this prompts that sort
of says hey you're watching this content
maybe like to watch his other content as
well and the idea here is of course that
you know if you see something you might
like other people might have also seen
stuff that you might like which another
aware of it so the organization's for
the Komatsu versus said hey would you
like to maybe you know do some
recommender stuff maybe do something
with algorithms and the way it kind of
worked it I'll be paraphrasing a little
bit when I joined this project there
were like two months of data like one of
our engineers started collecting data
making some stacks and stuff and it's
not like they didn't have anything at
the moment like their editorial
department had like a rule-based system
that was actually not the worst idea
like if you watch something from a
certain broadcaster maybe recommend
something that's popular from the same
broadcaster like in that sort of realm
they kind of already have something and
when we started talking to them they
were sort of thinking like yeah like if
you could cost 25 percent clicks that
would be kind of a nice goal if you get
like 25 percent clicks extra then your
recommenders sort of doing better and
I've been talking with them and they
were really really like they really
understood the product in this sense we
quickly came to the conclusion that
clicks is not the thing we're interested
in if you can optimize for clicks what
you're going to do then it's like click
dating instead what we said was we like
it if people click we like it even more
if people watch the content after the
click so it's really cool if you're
gonna watch the next episode of the show
but if not gonna watch it like the click
is okay we want you to watch it
afterwards and as we were sort of
discussing this there were people in
my filter bubble around me that we're
suggesting like all you got to do
recommender you should totally check out
this thing called deep learning and what
I kind of want to mention is like a lot
of people at this point in time say oh
there's so many algorithms here's a
paper here's a paper you should totally
do deep learning and what I just want to
mention that's hopefully the obvious
thing the first thing you do is not
consider deep learning the first thing
you do is you draw something up like
this because you're trying to understand
the problem it better so what we have
was like a part where we had like the
video player and it was sort of the user
interface and out of that came like okay
this user if we're going to check if a
recommender is better we also need to
have some sort of way to do a be testing
like if I cannot prove that my algorithm
is better than your algorithm if there's
no way to sort of put you in a in the B
group and then if I think about it after
that happens probably I'm not going to
be able to calculate these things on the
fly because it might be a heavy
calculation so I'm probably gonna be
needing a database and the database is
kind of like a caching mechanism such as
I can say okay this item maps to all of
these items and I should definitely
calculate that beforehand and if I have
a database I need something of a cron
job or air flow where the new data comes
in and then there's like an algorithm
that I can apply that put yourself into
this database but even after that
thinking about the problem again I
cannot probably cannot recommend all the
material all the time so as great as die
hard is as a movie to some people I
should never recommend that after Sesame
Street and I don't know if it's like
normal for me to expect that the
algorithm will always automatically pick
this up there's a lot of artificial
stupidity that could happen there so I
do need some sort of checking mechanism
just to be sure that nothing bad will
happen and you know this is one of the
first things you typically do you draw a
thing like this but one thing I want to
point out the algorithm is like a small
cog in this entire system it's all the
stuff around the algorithm that actually
brings the solution to the table and
will make everything work this algorithm
is like small beans compared to the rest
of it and I do hope it's sort of obvious
that like 90% of the effort in sort of
engineering and all that it's not the
algorithm it's all the other stuff so
it's imagine the deep learning people
around me they were sort of like okay
that sort of makes sense let's let's
build all that first so yes imagine then
the project went on and again I'm
paraphrasing but let's imagine that we
built everything below the algorithm
stuff here and then the deep learning
people's
come in the office again they say I
wanna do deep learning let me use tensor
flow and then there will be a very good
time to say no because the thing you
probably wanna do first because if
you're gonna use an a/b testing system
and you want that a be testing system is
sort of be reliable for the next five
years the first thing you probably wanna
do is test this a be testing system
because it's very like it happens
sometimes that this a B testing system
is not purely random that there's some
sort of bias that certain people from
certain areas of the Netherlands maybe
are overpopulated in the a group as
opposed in the B group and I would
really really hate it if five years from
now I discover that the a/b testing
system is broken so there's nothing
wrong with running an a a test it's like
one of those things where if you just do
that your solution is already a bit more
reliable so again you just imagine
there's some deep learning people that
sort of go okay that's also reasonable I
guess sure but then again there were
some some thoughts like okay once you do
that can you then do deep learning and
then again we sort of said no because
there's some other stuff you can do
that's also better for the solution
which you can also do if you want to
understand the system how about we just
have an algorithm B there's nothing more
than just random stuff so I just give
you a random episode if you do that you
know that that's obviously not the best
algorithm but the cool thing is you do
measure how many people will click
anyway and if I want to compare my
algorithm to like people who click
anyway that margin is something that's
very interesting suppose that your
algorithm is like 2.2 percent people
that click and stuff but randomness will
have 2 percent that people click as well
then you get a pretty good proxy that
you probably do not understand the
problem and measuring that I think it's
a very good thing but it's one of those
steps that people sort of forget about
because they focus on the algorithm and
even after you do this before you do
deep learning there's another thing you
can sort of do because if you think
about bias and people clicking anyway
what you can also even do is like test
the order of things in here right so you
might even say something in the order of
well this algorithm things that one item
one is the best item well if people are
going to click the first item anyway how
about we put the best item of slot
number three maybe that way more people
will click in total because you can
convince more people to sort of click
the better thing and again this is one
of those moments where
it's a very good thing to just test and
you can totally do this before even
thinking about the algorithm because it
helps you understand the problem a whole
lot better
so if imagine like the team I was in we
were doing stuff like this we were
really really fundamentally just trying
to figure out you know is this sort of
the problem are we sort of getting a
system is just going to work and also
while doing this we were continually
testing to a be splitting stuff the
database scaling and the checking
mechanism these were all things that we
were really able to test they were
working properly so by this time the
deep learning people were getting kind
of antsy right so there's all these
algorithm people who are sort of waiting
all this time for us to sort of really
push the big algorithm is supposed to go
out and I kind of had to disappoint a
lot of them because when we were sort of
thinking about it we at some point said
you know instead of deep learning how
about we just recommend the next episode
which made the deep learning advocates
kind of go oh right
and again this I'm definitely
paraphrasing here it's not in the case
that they were like actually deep
learning people knocking the door and
demanding anything like that that's not
how it happened but I do notice a lot of
the times that there's these people who
sort of dream about a solution but not
about the problem and that is a problem
because if you think about it just to
emphasize a few of these hype cycles I
don't think the real issue in 2016 was
that we weren't using Apache spark I
still do not think that the problem in
2018 was that we were not using deep
learning I also do not think that this
year the problem is going to be they
were not using auto ml even though
hacker news is suggesting you should all
use it now I think the problem is
probably more in the sense that as a
data scientist you typically don't talk
to your end users and maybe you don't
regularly drink coffee with the working
people who are supposed to be using your
app and also think because we're
probably trained to really really think
about a sort of quantitative way about
our algorithms and of other systems that
maybe we forget about the qualitative
level about our system and the reason
why I think that that is so sort of
important that we don't lose eye of that
is because by doing all these
experiments and by sort of trying to
understand the system I was actually
able to design a really really good
algorithm here and to explain the
thought they're like imagine if you will
that like I have a couple of series I've
Series A F Series B I've got Series C
and let's suppose that I know that you
just watched series
a-and the overlap of people that watched
Series C and the people that watched
series B that's equal has 50 people who
watch both shows so to say the only real
difference is that this show is more
popular than that show well if that's
the case for this platform I think it's
a much much better idea to recommend C
because if you think about it be for
example an extreme case could be the
news and everyone could be watching the
news right that's something as you will
watch independent of our recommendations
it makes no sense to recommend something
is you got to be watching anyway and
with this philosophy in mind it was
relatively easy to just come up with
some sort of formula and the easy
version is just this is the overlap that
you saw in the chart before and this is
sort of the entire circle that we had in
a Venn diagram before this is the stuff
that I do like this is stuff that I
don't like if I just calculate this
between all the series I and J I have a
pretty good score function I'm basically
I have in my mind what I would like to
see in my algorithm and by just defining
the score function like this I also have
the algorithm there's some like tons of
benefits about this algorithm because
it's just counting right one of the
other cool things like sending you from
I to J is not equal to sending you from
J die but this simple formula like a
variant of this is still alive I think
at Dyea client and I've used this
algorithm a bunch and a bunch of times
and it turns out it works quite well if
your interest is that you want to cause
a lot of serendipity by thinking about
the problem you realize this is a
formula for serendipity this simple a
way to describe that and I believe the
algorithm is life today when we launched
it it caused some number X percent more
on the platform like instantly over the
weekend we just saw like skew going up
and we were also able to prove that we
weren't doing clickbait and this is I
think the coolest chart that I've ever
made in my career I do have to explain a
little bit but imagine if you will that
this was the chart for there for what
people click so if this is very high
then in 2016 if you click a
recommendation that comes from the
business rule engine most of the stuff
you will be clicking is from 2016 so
with this chart is sort of saying is if
you were getting your recommendations
from the business rules odds are that
the content you're watching is probably
from the most recent year but if you
were watching us from like my formula
with like the thing I came up with it
was actually kind of normal that people
would not just click but watch content
from like four years ago so we were able
to really prove that this algorithm
wasn't just giving people that what they
wanted to click on but we were actively
diversifying sort of all the content
that they were having and if you're like
a person who has lots of content but you
this is great because this is all
content you're not paying for anymore
and if you can still use we'll find ways
to get people interested in that content
that's a win-win because that's content
you don't have to pay for and for me at
least some of the lessons here was like
because I was able to qualitatively
think about this problem you know if you
have a good heuristic to for loops in an
if statement can totally whooping neural
network SAS that's it's kind of easy to
do you just have to understand the
problem very well and this mental thing
of taking a step back I'm wondering like
what's the actual problem that's a very
sort of nice way to get there and I
don't think there's any shame and trying
to understand the problem because if you
do a lot of these a B tests try to
understand your users that is a very
good progress towards a good solution
and blindly following a book or a blog
would probably not have given me this
approach and just to mention this is
this algorithm is really sweet because
if you look at the entire system there's
all sorts of parts that we can just go
ahead and replace so if the world
changes it's fairly easy probably an
assistant like this to sort of make
amends and make sure that you're able to
change it's the world changes yeah and
again I wouldn't simply not have gotten
here if I would have believed the true
like deep learning gospel or anything
like that they're just taking a step
back and wondering what am I actually
doing next episode and the heuristic
like this it really goes a long way and
this is like one situation where I was
very happy and able to sort of you know
avoid solving the wrong problem I think
but there's other situations as well and
to sort of exemplify how you might be
able to solve a problem by rephrasing it
what I will first do is give like a
mathematical introduction to what I mean
by that and then I will tell you a story
about how the world food organization as
has been told by me I was able to save a
bunch of lives
who here watch it like if ever you heard
of like 99% of visible the podcast you
raise your hand if you've seen like a
couple of you okay it's like an amazing
podcast and if you're interested in
having like very odd math questions to
solve listen to this podcast ago it's
about design and this is one episode
where there was a competition where if
you would live on the Billboard for as
long as possible you might be able to
win a house and it was like I think in
the 60s when there was a deep regret
recession in the United States and all
these candidates who got into this
competition
some of them wrote 10,000 letters to the
radio station in order to you know get
into this competition so that's the fun
math problem because what you want to do
is you want to maybe decide the optimal
number of letters to sent to the contest
and you'll lose if they open two of your
envelopes but you'll win if they open
only one so you want to send as many
envelopes as possible such that the odds
of opening one of them is very high but
not too much such as the odds of opening
two envelopes is higher and this is the
fun little math probably this is what I
do when I'm on the bus and if you know
this is listening to the podcast you
kind of go right there's like a couple
of free variables there's like the
number of contestants will be picked in
total there's a number of letters that
sort of I send in and there's a number
of letters that other people send in and
sort of the math equation like if you
only pick one contestant the odds of
being selected is just s over a plus s
there's a number of letters again that I
send in the map is not super important
but if only one person is picked it had
you just want to send as many letters as
possible and then if two people get
picked okay it's sort of the same thing
except you can be either the first
person who gets picked or you can be the
second person who gets picked and you
have to sort of follow the math but it
kind of gets tricky here because it's
not just s on top of the equation here
but it's also an S below the equation
here so it's a bit more of a complicated
formula if you want to do this for being
picked thrice I mean the beginning of
the math again is easy because you could
say okay you're either the first person
who gets elected the second person who
gets elected or the third one first
second third
but if then if you combine that into
like one formula it gets kind of tricky
because you want to optimize for s and s
is above the division as well as below
so differentiating this is kind of
tricky
there's a very cool tool called senpai
you can just throw it in there and
usually it solves everything
but even simply had a problem because
differentiating basically made the
equation longer and trying to solve this
for zero my computer just gave up at
some point so this is actually kind of a
very tricky math problem because you
have to differentiate a free variable as
both above the dividers below but but
here's the funny thing if you just take
this one small step to rephrase one
thing what I could do is I could say how
about I take a plus s and that's equal
to T and I'll have that be the constant
and s still be the free variable but I
can rephrase this equation into this one
and again T is now a constant and this
is a polynomial that's and super easy to
solve this is like not even a calculus
exam my calculus exam questions are way
harder than this typically so then you
have a closed form solution and it's
great and the only way that you would
have gotten here is you would have the
insight that your math equation needed
to be rephrased that was sort of the
thing the trick that made this a lot
easier than it had to be is it the easy
as easy as it should be and this is like
a very small mental step right just
rephrase like one equation and that's it
but I've noticed at the machine learning
there's a lot of opportunities where a
similar thing sort of happens it's very
hard to recognize but rephrasing is
actually a very awesome tool to solve a
real-world problem and again I'm about
to tell you a problem I heard the second
hand I was at the different conference
for operations research people so I
wasn't involved in any of this research
but I think the drive at the point that
I'm baking will derive everything home
so if I imagine if you're the world food
organization you tried it like there's a
lot of villages let's say that are in
short native food so what you can do as
a village you can sort of say hey I need
red beans and beef and then there are
some volunteers at the world food
organization who are into like
logistical algorithms like the
operations Research Group typically and
they will find a very efficient
logistical scheme to make sure that this
town gets the bread the beans and the
beef and these are typically quite
complicated algorithms so you have a
couple of shipping ports you gotta keep
in mind at a couple of villages you have
to keep in mind there's like transport
costs and that sort of thing as a feel
ability of crops and all that stuff
super interesting problem but they are
very hard these things are like np-hard
people thought they were so high
they came up with two letters for it
also like these algorithms typically
don't scale well at all often you need
to have like one single machine because
it's not something you can distribute
easily and it's not unheard of to hear
stories of servers running for like days
and weeks to solve a problem and he's
usually like the algorithms that you
consider they don't even have like a
guarantee of optimality so you have a
crista feeties initialization cheapest
for this insertion to three opt and
kneeling greedy so if they imagine that
there's like lots and lots of experts
like really clever people trying to sort
of apply all of these things so maybe
get to the optimal solution and stuff
but the thing is and the algorithm
doesn't matter because they were solving
the wrong problem because if you hear
someone say I need bread beans and beef
but you should really hear it say I need
carbohydrates fiber and protein
I don't need beans I need nutrients and
you know you might have heard of this
stickler diet problem but if you think
about it the human being needs like a
couple of grams of you know calcium a
few grams of protein calories etc but
you can get them from many different
foodstuffs right and certain foodstuffs
are cheaper than other foodstuffs and
what's more certain foodstuffs are just
closer than others it might be that the
place that has lentils for your town is
a lot closer than the place that has
beans it might be the case that if you
have lentils you only need a truck and
then the case if you have beans you need
some sort of shipyard to get the ship
from a different port now imagine that
you're sort of design trying to design
an algorithm here you can write the best
algorithm ever for this problem but if
you have to find the problem in the
wrong way if not done is one rephrasing
trick you're still solving the wrong
problem and let's be honest here this is
one of those things that the algorithm
will not be able to figure out on its
own you probably want to design an
algorithm to take this sort of stuff
into account because if the algorithm
isn't aware of this search space it
won't be able to look in it and like the
best thing in life of course is that you
can go for something like this for
something like this right this is what
you're trying to do you're not trying to
write a paper about the coolest
algorithm anything like this but in this
situation you might be saving lives and
that's sort of I think a cooler thing
than optimizing for an ROC curve
and and I do think there's like this
risk that if you're in a team where only
algorithm people reside it might be very
hard to test the algorithm in the real
world because if you really want to look
at the problem from multiple angles your
team probably needs to be a bit more
into blister-like interdisciplinary in
this particular example and again I
heard about a third hand so I'll just
assume it's mostly true but it wasn't
the algorithm that saved the world
rather he understanding of it a better
algorithm in this case definitely would
have had a worse outcome if it was used
on the wrong problem
and again like taking a step back and
rethinking turns out to be a pretty good
trick
it turns out though that this is one of
those real-world examples but the whole
taking a step back thing you can also
use that to win in very mechanical very
algorithmic challenges as well so now I
would like to talk about a cattle
problem who here does Kegel once in a
while not a whole lot of people I don't
either but there's this one challenge
every year where they have well they
have something with Santa and those are
sort of more the operations research
problems and like the the purely
mathematical optimize the system type
problems which is kind of my background
so those are the problems I really
really like and the problem that Kaggle
surly came up with is basically he said
you know we santa forgot how much the
gifts way so I might be able to put a
book in the bag I might be able to put a
ball in the bag and then I have one bank
with gifts might be able to put another
book and another two balls in a
different bag but if I put too much
gifts in a bag there's a probability to
the bag my trip and the thing I got
optimizes I want to have as many bags as
possible with with as much weight as
possible but I never want to bag to rip
and I don't know exactly how much these
things weigh the only thing I know is
that these things come from a
distribution if Cal was nice enough to
supply in this numpy code so horses wait
a certain amount of stuff books wait a
certain amount of stuff blocks and
trains and whatnot and sort of what you
kind of get then is this awkward moment
where you sort of have to consider am I
gonna do like lots of light bags and
then none of the bags will rip right
that's a tactic then I'm at least very
sure that what I send the Kegel is
actually in the score what you can also
do is go for the other out you can kind
of say oh screw it I'll just
some of the backs might be ripped but
I'm compensating because all the other
bags will have lots of stuff in it
or you can kind of make a mix of these
two things right but this is basically
the problem when I send one allocation
of all these bags to cackled I get one
score back and it's the total sum of all
the non rips bags so I don't get a whole
lot of information back and you know if
your operations research person the
first thing you do is you write stuff
like this down so what are you
optimizing and what a sort of the
constraint so the way that I was sort of
thinking about the problem was you just
have to sort of assign an item to a bag
and then you can sort of take the
expected value of that item as sort of
the thing you gain but you have to do
this with the constraint because you
want to minimize the risk that you're
gonna get near the max weight and I
thought I did pretty cool with him
there's a colleague of mine yealt I was
doing this we had a really great time as
a fun puzzle so I used our tools with
some simulated weights and I generate
lots of solutions and I sort of had a
tactic above like upload often and pray
not the best tactic I can say we've had
a lot of fun so it's fun and other
people they also did sort of the the
guessing game so they would like upload
three times a day really try to sort of
learn the weight of this one little gift
and then sort of the game became that a
lot of people were sort of calculating
how many uploads they needed in order to
perfectly solve the problem so to say
and the forum was great because you just
read whatever people are doing there's
lots of hackings and stuff but a lot of
the problems were sort of around this
solution as well so I was content and
then after a few weeks as someone on the
forum demonstrated that everyone was
solving the wrong problem and let's
focus on an epic hint the cackle gave us
this is how everything was generated
right so presumably one part of the coda
they did not show was this alright so
I'm about to read a part of the Kaggle
forum for you and this was actually on
the Congo forum so this was someone the
guy named with a guy's name was Toby
cheese and if you're out there on
YouTube again this was one of the things
that you know made my day so what he
read what he said was there was one
thing left in this competition that I
wanted to do ever since a discussion
started and that thing was to see if
maybe it's possible to brute force the
seed values used to generate the toy
weights imagine my disappointment when I
actually succeeded
[Laughter]
and then there's some extra information
apparently the the number of possible
seeds is only like somewhere in the like
four billion area instead of like
multiples of ten higher than that
because of some weird numpy internals
the wolf I need to make a talk to you
about that I'm interested to know your
story and also there's a seating so like
you can paralyze this on many different
computers which is what the guy did
essentially he like this giant for loop
and totally paralyzed that and all sorts
of cores and the thing was he submitted
one score and if any one of his sort of
random seeds sort of met that one
allocation perfectly bang you've got
your hit and all your risk is gone
here's the official statement from
kaggle so the cackle team said yes I'm
embarrassed to admit that in my pre
holiday scramble to put this together
I thought about extra seeds to vary it
but I didn't do it well enough so we had
like two random seed points it wasn't
enough as a that was still enough
information that Toby was able to learn
and this is this was like one of those
marvelous moments where you're just
thinking I get that it's like really
hard to think outside of the box when
you're in it and that's also sort of why
this like hilarious
awesome optimal solution okay goal was
almost an afterthought but this will
happen in real life for us as well it's
not just the real-world problem this is
probably gonna be the algorithmic
problems as well and I kind of have it
like this a personal theory that I got
from John Cleese but like I do think
maybe a way to deal with this is like it
does show that good ideas pop around
when you're not in like work work mode
it's a lot better it's a sort of try to
get these ideas when you're sort of more
in a work play five minutes great got
you so I think encouraging this work
play mode thing is kind of like a
no-brainer if you're an organization
you've got a bunch of smart creative
people just give them some playtime once
in a while because I think that's the
only way that you're able to get sort of
hacks like this in your team and it
might just be super beneficial to your
business and the next story will
demonstrate this point even more and I
will say with this story it is I think
hilarious but it's very hard to verify
if it's true I read in the book it's
true but the books from the 80s but as a
story goes right it's about a time
series problem but as the story goes
there is a condom Factory and they kind
of have this prob
because the thing is when you make your
product either the factory has to be on
and you make lots of the thing and then
you have to move it to the warehouse but
both the factory and the warehouse are
like super expensive and they're really
hard to turn on and off because you hire
the factory in a lot of cases so then
what you got to do is you got a sort of
plan when the factory can be on or off
because the competitor might be using
the factory at the same time so you can
have to be able to plan this around if
you will so then a clever guy supposedly
came up with a business case and the
idea was as follows it was like the 90s
80s I suppose right so yeah this like
small army of consultants and suits
let's call them the Econometrica army
and the business case I sort of got was
they basically said look if you can
predict the demand for this product then
we were much able to plan the factory
and then also we're much much better to
plan like the warehouse and it's like
going to be a huge huge cost saver like
this this will be great so the
Econometrica army supposedly in a story
they they went in they fiddled around
there of two months but they came back
and said yep it's really hard to predict
no dice so management is like super
disappointed and then you know as a
story would go like one of the managers
having a walk in the park and it sort of
occurred to the to the manager person
because if you think about it the
problem sort of is that we want to
predict this time series p1 but it turns
out that p1 is impossible to predict and
apparently because it's hard to predict
that's the thing that makes planning the
the factory kind of hard so how about we
ignore the time series but we do
something that makes the planning of the
factory super easy because what you
could also do them as you can sort of
say you know what how about I just find
a different product made from the same
material that correlates negatively if
there is such a product where if you
know product one is super high product
two is super low and vice versa then
there's no need to predict the market
because you're always able to produce
something supposedly this is how latex
pacifiers got invented
I don't know if this is true but I do
like the story and I like the story so
much because when I read the story for
the first time I really took me by
surprise like I'm an algorithmic person
I'm trained with the idea that my
algorithm thing is the thing that solves
the other thing but this is one of those
examples where it's sort of obvious that
the only way you're gonna get the
solution is if you allow yourself a bit
more creativity if you're a liar or cell
to sort of think out the box and maybe
as you know if we want the AR winner to
sort of never happen if you want to sort
of convince people in suits that machine
learning is great maybe we also need to
get better at understanding the theater
and like recommending next episode and
considering lentils / beans and pivoting
the pacifiers and that sort of thing
because the more and more I started
thinking about it and some of the crazy
stuff that I hear from like my peers
like I really fundamentally think that
understanding the problem it's much more
important than the selling the solution
and just in general I think we should
maybe take a step back and think more
about the system around the algorithm
and when you're designing a system it's
probably a much better idea than a focus
on a single part but rather maybe the
communication between two parts like
having a bit more of a holistic view
there might be like a really good thing
and especially in this case like it's
kind of Zen but rephrasing might be your
best friend it's like take a lot someone
was routine reflect on what you're doing
maybe you've rephrase the problem in the
wrong way and when you're doing that
you're probably gonna realize that maybe
need to stop being just a data team and
maybe just need to be more of an
interdisciplinary team that owns a part
of the like the product or the product
team or something like that don't live
in a rabbit hole you should really try
to prevent this intellectual laziness
it's really ok to have to admit that you
might not really fully understand the
problem and it's definitely ok
also for burnout reasons to take a break
once in a while and a lot of these
problems I really think they solve
themselves if you go running or just
have like one of your banter moments
like only Dutch people will get that
reference but if you just have one of
those banter moments with your friends
in the bar and I guess the only thing I
have to say after this is like go to
your local theatre because there's
amazing stuff to see on stage Thanks
[Music]
[Applause]